ملعب الثمامه في الدوحه يشتعل فرحا
فالجماهير داخل الاستاذ داخل هذا ستاد
الذي يشاهد خلفي يقومون بقرع الطبول
والجميع هنا يعني ينتظر في هذه المنطقه
نحن على امام الملعب ينتظرون دخول همم
مشاهده المباراه وفي نفس الوقت يشاهدونها
على هواتفهم الجوال كمان نشاهد هنا
النتيجه حتى الان طبعا 2-1 كامل المفروض
تكون ثلاثه واحد بس للاسف نحن يعني في
الدقيقه 52 من المباراه وهناك كثير من
المشجعين ال- ال- المغاربه الذين ينتظرون
كما كنت قبل قليل دخول الملعب انت من وين
من اي مدينه من المغرب
من المملكه المغربيه
الفرصه انني نخش الملعب نعم على كل حال
ميسون يوجد الكثير من الشباب المغربي هنا
الذين اتوا على متن الطائرات اليوم بعد
ظهر اليوم هناك 16 طائره المملكه من
المملكه المغربيه وصلت الى الدوحه هنا
مطار حمد بعد ظهر اليوم اتيه من المغرب
تحمل مشجعين لهذا لهذا الماتش لهذه
المباراه التي قد تاهل ان شاء الله
المنتخب المغربي الى المنتخب الى
الدور الثامن او المرحله الثامنه نعم نعم
الحمد لله احنا وخامه دخلناش الملعب احنا
فرحانين النتيجه لان الحمد لله من 86 احنا
ما تاهلناش مطور ثاني وهذه فرصه في هذه
الدول العربيه لاخوتنا واحنا في وسط
بلادنا الحمد لله احنا فرحانين كثير
ومتصدرين المجموعه حاليا ميسون اذا اخذنا
الكاميرا
القوات الامن سمحت ال ال الذين لا يحملون
تذاكر او بطاقات لحضور المباراه بالدخول
وذلك طبعا لان هناك همم بعض الذين تاخروا
او الذين تغيبوا عن حضور المباراه مع انهم
يحملون تذاكر لحضور هذا الماتش بين المغرب
همم
وكندا والكثير يعني من الذين اذا دخلنا من
هذه من هذا من هذا الممر سن نشاهد ان
الجميع هنا ينتظر لانه هناك تقديم ميسون
في دخول الشباب المغربي او المشجعون
المغربي المغاربه الى الى داخل الاستوديو
وهناك طبعا انتظار وهناك همم من يراق- من
يشاهد يعني هذا الشخص كما نشاهد نشاهد
المباراه على جواله ويرصد ما يحدث على ارض
الملعب كم النتيجه بعد ما تغيرت صح ان شاء
الله دقيقه الخامسه والخمسون من المباراه
انت من اي بلد من المغرب من المغرب من
مدينه زاكوره عفوا زاكوره زاكوره من
المغرب
نعم يعني انت برضو شامله تشجع ولا انت
مقيم هنا انا الحين مقيم هنا وجاي يشجع ان
شاء الله
ثلاث الواحد
ثلاثه واحد ولكن كما قلنا قبل قليل لم
يحسم لم يحسب هذا الهدف الذي سجل قبل قليل
ولكن المباراه مستمره ونعمل يعني هناك همم
الحلو المشجعين المغاربه ميسون انهم عندما
يعني اذكر تماما عندما فازوا قبل هذه
المره في مباريات هنا كاس العالم توجه راس
مباشره الى جامع الى الى ساحه همم سوق
واقف وتم هناك طبعا الكثير من الاحتفالات
وقرع الطبول والوزن والرفع الاعلام
المغربيه والاعلام العربيه وهذا كان شيء
جميل يعني نعمل ان يربح المغرب وان يؤهل
على الاقل بلد عربي الى الدوري الثامن من
من المباريات وهنا يعني الكثير يريد ان
اتكلم الى الكاميرا وهناك اشخاص من وين
حضرتك
اكيد بس من وين من اي منطقه
انا مقيم في الدوحه
من السودان
ايوه نعم ايوه كلنا جينا نشجع جيب معه
واسود الاطلس ونتمنى لهم الفوز ان شاء
الله يعني هناك الحلو
من المشجعين العرب
ويريدون ليس فقط يشجعوهم عن بعد بالايضا
دخول الى ساحه الى ارض الملعب الى الى
ستديوم الى الى الملعب
المنتخب المغربي وكما نعلم يعني اذا كان